on September 21st in Lake Odessa
Michigan Joanne Jacobson was canvassing
against a pro-abortion ballot
proposition that was that was up for a
vote and so she was going around
neighborhoods as a lot of campaigners do
uh expressing her views and persuading
her fellow citizens and was all going
just fine until she got to one home the
Harvey residents where the woman Mrs
Harvey instantly became very very
hostile was clearly very supportive of
abortion and I suppose I suppose Mrs
Harvey is entitled to her opinions but
then what happened is Mrs Harvey's
husband came out with a gun with a
loaded gun
and shot Joanne Jacobson Joanne is 84
years old 120 pounds retired nurse not
someone you would say is presenting a
particular physical threat to you or
your family
shot and this story has received
basically no coverage anywhere in the
establishment media because it
contradicts the pro-abortion narratives
that they're all trying to sell so we
think that it is only right and just and
fair to have a Joanne on with her lawyer
attorney Steve Coleman to to just
explain what happened Joanne thank you
so much for coming on the show I'm so
sorry to hear about what happened to you
well thank you for having me
I I would say I'm I'm so sorry to hear
what happened to you I'm so happy to
hear that you escaped obviously the
situation could have gone way
differently and you would not be sitting
here talking about this today so just if
you wouldn't mind what happened
you mean start from the beginning please
yeah okay well I went to the door or I
told her why I was being there and she
identified herself as being Mrs Harvey
and immediately when I mentioned
proposal three and voting no she got
very angry antagonistic and said that no
she was gonna vote no on it and I said
to her I kept calm I didn't raise my
voice and I said did she know that it
was going to amend the State
Constitution and she just said she
didn't care she was gonna vote no and
then she proceeded to tell me that she
had had a tubal pregnancy
and I said to her I said well
there's always been an exception for the
life of the mother because in this
situation that's what happens they have
to take the baby because it's not going
to be able to mature in the fallopian
tube and so um
you know
I I said I told her again a second time
and I don't think that she understood
but I was saying about it it's an
exception to the life of the mother and
obviously her life was in danger
well she keeps yelling and she says well
I don't want this to happen to anybody
else and I can't even have a chance to
explain to her that yes this is going to
happen to somebody else medicine doesn't
know doesn't know
to my knowledge when a mother's going to
have an ectopic pregnancy there's
nothing that they can do to stop it and
um
so she then immediately says you don't
have a right to be here and get off my
property
to which I replied I'm going so I just
got down the steps through three or four
steps to get up to the port
um
got on the sidewalk I'm carrying a
clipboard because I have a list of homes
that I'm going to go visit
and they're telling me I had my umbrella
because it was raining that day I
couldn't tell the police for sure if I
had the umbrella or not
so I'm hanging onto my clipboard and my
umbrella
and it's a long sidewalk it's not like
the city it's a long sidewalk from the
home
to the driveway 50 60 feet
and so I'm about 12 15 feet down on the
sidewalk and she's behind me yelling so
she's she's following you as you walk
away well yeah I mean she's off the
porch she's on right at the bottom of
the steps
and she's on her cell phone and she's
yelling at me constantly I don't
remember everything that she yelled but
she was yelling get off my property
and so I kept going in
as I'm walking out of the corner of my
eye
I saw that there was a man there was a
barn on the on the property there was a
man walking alongside the barn
didn't think anything of it he didn't
come up and talk to me but please ask me
well was he carrying a gun I can't tell
you if he was carrying a gun or not
um
you didn't come and talk to me you went
around the back of me and I'm just
assuming he's going up to his home
really didn't think I think of it keep
walking and
um get me on my clipboard and my
umbrella they told me I had the umbrella
and um
she's yelling constantly behind me
you know get off my property
and then at some point she's all of a
sudden she's alongside of me I'm on the
sidewalk and she's in the grass
but five or six feet away from me
and I and I I looked out for some reason
and
the police said that there were two
shots
I had only heard one shot
so I'm thinking what made me look up
is the fact I do have some hearing
problem
that I heard something
didn't recognize it as being a gunshot
and then
so I'm turning sideways and looking and
I see the man is standing next to her
in the grass
and as soon as I realized he was
standing there I I know the first thing
I noticed was he had this gun long
barrel gun
and by the time
just a matter of seconds it's like
I heard the shot and I felt this pain
and I thought oh he shipped me in the
back because I had intense paint in the
back
and
they didn't say anything and I didn't
think I said anything but I've been told
she evidently was taping what was
happening
that I said did he shoot me I thought I
just said it to myself
he didn't say anything she didn't say
anything and that was all I said and I
started walking to my car
as I because I almost at the end of the
sidewalk so I'm pretty much closer to my
car
I get I open up the door and I'm
thinking am I going to be able to drive
I don't know how badly I was hurt
and so I didn't feel dizzy or faint or
no any other symptoms other than pain
so I thought well I think I can get in
the car and drive and so I didn't call
9-1-1
got it getting ready to get behind the
wheel and I happened to look through the
windshield of the car and they're both
still standing there
and I told the cop I said for a fleeting
second I thought this guy's gonna shoot
me again he's going to shoot right
through the window
well fortunately he didn't I get in the
car you didn't gear back up get on the
road
and think what am I going to do I
thought well I've got to tell the police
so I drove to the police station in Lake
Odessa
probably be about three miles or so
I get there and the village manager
comes out and he says what can I do for
you and I said I think I've been shot
and shot he said and I I turned around I
said can you see anything
and she had up here on my shoulder of
course I can't see it
and he immediately said to me he's the
go sit down on that couch over there and
the next thing I know I'm surrounded by
about five or six people and they're
wanting to take off my top and they're
telling me no no no don't move keep your
back straight and they're putting
they're rolling me and putting me on a
board and before I knew it I'm in the
ambulance and I'm on a way to the
emergency room so so the shot landed it
was in your back it was in your shoulder
it was
yeah he went over that because my
turning sideways it hit the right the
top of my right shoulder and exited out
my back
up in the thoracic area of the spine
and I was told by the doctors that I was
one lucky person because it just
narrowly missed my spine
um fortunate otherwise the reason I
could drive is because it didn't get any
major vessels and it didn't hit the bone
so that's why I was able to safely I
didn't think I was going to endanger
myself or you know anybody else on the
road to get behind the car and and drive
to the police station Joanne I have to
tell you there are some times when I
stub my toe and I feel that I can't
drive so the fact that you were able to
drive after being shot is
extraordinarily impressive and thank God
that the people at the police station
were able to say sit down we're taking
you to the emergency room we're going to
treat you
[Music]
[Music]